we are going to hear from the most
important people in our ecosystem
the viewers the listeners the audience
if it weren't for you there would be no
show I would probably still own a
microphone but I wouldn't be able to do
anything interesting with it that's for
damn sure we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord The Waiting
Lobby is where you go if you want to
chat with me and let's see the degree of
technical problems that will plague us
today I want to start here with Alex
from Baltimore Alex from Baltimore
welcome what is on your mind today
hey Dave can you hear me yes I can
alrighty so first question I've been
meaning to ask you
anyone who listens to your live calls
and live streams knows you're very
particular about your bagels so as
someone who's a little more vagal
illiterate for lack of a better term
what makes a David packman approved
beggle
well you need the right ratio of crunchy
on the outside and pillowy soft on the
inside it's it's almost an ethereal
thing that's beyond description you just
need to bite into it and you know right
away
okay and it doesn't matter like the
topping of bagel or is this I mean
listen uh you're not gonna see me with a
french toast Bagel anytime soon of
course the topping matters absolutely
the the really if you're looking for a
sweet Bagel you go cinnamon raisin but
all of these you know strawberry Bagels
French toast oatmeal pancake Bagel
chocolate chip no no no no it's not for
me I'm a purist
now I agree uh Savory bagels are better
than sweet Bagels I would say I would
say so okay all right uh real question
so this is based off of a book I read
recently
um
would you say is do would you give any
ingredients to the idea that
the president of the United States just
flat out has too much to handle and that
no matter who it is
what their uh beliefs are they're just
gonna have a hard time and they're not
going to be particularly good at their
job no I don't agree with that I mean I
think there's sort of two different
questions here there's the question of
does the president of the United States
have too many responsibilities in terms
of Delegation and then there's the
separate question of whether they're all
going to be bad at their jobs I think
that there are lots of presidents who
were good at their jobs I mean President
Obama was good at his job you never got
the sense that he just couldn't keep up
with all the different things that were
under his purview I think the more
interesting question or maybe the more
accurate
assessment that could be made is they're
they're simply need to be significantly
more diplomats because as we know a lot
of these issues they touch the
presidency but then they are the details
are sort of handled by the diploma attic
core that the Diplomatic core should be
bolstered and should be bigger I think
that's a fair assessment to make but of
course the right says we need the
smallest possible government so by
definition they're against enlarging The
Diplomatic Corps
gotcha and uh the book is uh the hardest
job in the world by John Dickerson who's
on CBS actually yeah it was actually it
was actually an interesting book that
wasn't his only point it was also like a
mini history of the presidency and how
even like mundane responsibilities like
evolved and kind of pile up on on their
day-to-day and make the job a little
harder another slight thing they he said
was uh
how the President also has to be a great
campaigner and great at governing and
that a lot of people can't aren't
necessarily the best at doing both like
I'm sure there's a bunch of senators it
would be great presidents I think of a
Amy Klobuchar or a um
on Elizabeth Warren but who on The Stomp
just don't seem to impress anybody so
but they would be great once they got in
the chair I would go even further
there's there I completely agree there's
people who would never even run because
the idea of the political campaign is so
off-putting to them who would still be
really good presidents if they somehow
ended up in that position so I
absolutely agree with that
yeah and that was just a
that was just a good point I thought all
right well that's all I had I will talk
to you next time all right thank you
very much for the call I appreciate it